there's uh unfortunately sadly a lot of
people that look up to you that is a
horrible thing but life is a nightmare
yeah
uh if you were to give them advice young
young folks people in college maybe even
high school but people in their 20s
about what to do with their life uh
whether it's career whether it's just
life in general what would you say
ignore everyone make a few good friends
truly have honest conversations with
yourself about your
what when do you feel the most alive
figure that out
when and how do you feel the most alive
yeah
figure that out
try to figure out a job or a career that
can replicate that feeling
um
don't listen to anyone don't listen to
your parents don't listen to the gurus
on the internet don't listen to me don't
listen to anyone figure out
you know where you feel the most alive
where do you feel excited where do you
where does your pulse Quicken what do
you feel matters when you're in a
situation do you feel like it matters
uh what situation was that what got you
excited what thing did you walk into
where you looked around and were taken
back and you're like wow this is amazing
and I'm I'm filled with awe if you can
figure out a life where you you can
excite yourself you might not use drugs
or alcohol or a sex addiction or
gambling or irresponsibility you might
not have to get your [ __ ] kicks in
very destructive places if you can get
them in a productive place we gotta you
have a pretty
weaving like that's full of uh mistakes
and so on many mistakes
is that our mistakes a bugger feature
like do you recommend uh embrace the
mistakes make a bunch of them depends
what they are right so you you've had
the full spectrum I've had a lot but a
lot of mine could have sunk me right
like they sound like fun when I talk
about them but they actually could have
sunk me and they were all part of what
made me funny but I don't know I would
never tell anyone else to just light
their life on fire and hope it works out
on the other end it would be pretty
irresponsible but hey
at the end of the day it's like
you're gonna we get there's you know I
think one of my themes is that there's
too much we give the power we think we
have two The Power of Choice has been
elevated on our society to uh an
unhealthy degree
I think people are I think you could you
could get really good at something but
you're born with a certain aptitude it
might be to be a deal maker might be to
be an athlete it might be to be an
artist it might be to be a romantic just
fall in and out of love in and out of
love and I love it might be to be like a
world traveler like but whatever you are
I think you are I think that there's
something about you that makes you
something and if you can figure it out
and then refine you're not going to be
good at it per se but if you're if
you're an athlete it might not mean that
you're going to be a great athlete in
the history but it might mean you're the
best coach anyone's ever had or you're
the person that you know builds a local
scene for young athletes or whatever if
you are a really good deal maker it
doesn't mean you're gonna be Warren
Buffett but it might mean you're
somebody who enjoys making deals all the
time and things like that like if you're
an Entertainer it might mean that you
are an Entertainer it might mean that
you are in the world of entertainment
because you love it so much that if you
lack the skill set to really pursue it
on a degree you just want to be like
there's a up there's a thing inside of
you that makes you what you are I think
I look at certain people and I go you
were born to be that thing you know the
whole purpose is to find it I was a
juror on that murder trial on a murder
trial in Long Island and the the woman
who's a D.A I'm like you were born to do
this you were born to put murderers away
and this guy killed the mother of his
children he was a bad guy but like I was
like you are really good at what you do
she has a strong belief in whatever her
moral code is and what her justice and
ethics are and she wants to communicate
that to people she was very good at at
doing what she did I don't know the
facts of the case I didn't really listen
he seemed guilty so I just voted guilty
but she I didn't really listen to her
but I heard the shape of her mouth was
very bovine like a cow and it it
conferred a certain level of expertise
that I enjoyed it was funny I mean you
could see you're half joking yeah you
can often see that people just this they
found their place they found their role
found their thing they found their thing
and that's kind of the purpose of life
and once you are in a in a place that
seems sticky like the place that seems
right you know that's one of the
problems with the generation that you're
speaking to is there's always a feeling
like I should keep exploring keep
exploring but it's okay to stay in a
place that you found that works yeah and
listen sometimes the best place you'll
find is like when people are like when
did you feel really excited and alive
it's like doing nothing
right yeah you know like that's the
other thing it's like some people could
be like I feel really excited and alive
and I'm laying in my backyard in a
hammock yeah and I just wanted the
simplest life and not have to do much
and I don't like doing anything and I
love laying around and going wow this
guy looks good today yeah Bill Gates
goes to Scott looks good today let's
shoot a missile into it he wants to do
[ __ ] right so it's like in between that
and nothing is you can find something
but in that process
for you personally I mean for me for
others I think there's a struggle when
you look in the when Tim Dylan looks in
the mirror do you love yourself do you
hate yourself well a lot of times I
think I'm Amy Schumer so I'm confused
I'm a day taunt with myself all the time
I don't love myself or hate myself
addicts have a very uh bad uh problem
where you can't just fall in love with
yourself and you can't hate yourself
both of them lead you to a negative
place you try to stay kind of even Keel
I don't go like hey man you put out a
video get all these views things are
great you sold a bunch of tickets let's
[ __ ] go out like maybe let's hey man
let's have that drink that you've been
waiting for for 11 years and I don't
look at myself and go you ate a Burger
yesterday you're a piece of [ __ ] you're
horrible you'll never you know get into
the shape you want like I try not to get
too low or too high both of them are not
good from my particular mind